albert einstein is unquestionably the
most iconic scientist in modern times
he pretty much sets the image most
people have for what a physicist looks
like a white man with a mustache wild
white hair a german accent and an
otherworldly air
einstein is so firmly lodged in people's
imagination as the canonical scientist
that as late as 2009 he was the second
most popular choice of people asked to
name a living scientist
despite the survey being taken 54 years
after his death
einstein's name also conjures up images
of some of the most brain-bending
theories in the history of science he's
best known for his theories of
relativity which transformed our
understanding of space and time
special relativity tells us that time
depends on how you're moving a moving
clock ticks more slowly than one at rest
general relativity tells us that the
very structure of space and time is
warped by gravity making clocks tick
more slowly near massive objects and
bending light onto curved paths but
einstein also made key contributions to
the theory of quantum mechanics which
tells us that light waves actually
behave like particles and that material
particles like electrons actually have
some wave nature
in his later years he broke with a
theory over philosophical difficulties
relating to the randomness inherent in
quantum theory and the spooky
interactions that seemed to connect
particles over long distances
he was wrong about some of these
concerns but even his mistaken ideas
still proved to be insightful and
stimulated later breakthroughs
together these theories have utterly
transformed our understanding of the
universe and our place in it
they have also proven enormously
important for modern technology
particularly quantum physics
without an understanding of the quantum
nature of electrons we wouldn't be able
to make the computer chips that are
central to so many modern devices
without an understanding of the quantum
nature of light a topic einstein made
key early contributions to we wouldn't
be able to make the lasers that carry
the internet over a global network of
fiber optic cables
without both quantum physics and
relativity we wouldn't have the global
positioning system to help us navigate
through our daily lives
both quantum mechanics and relativity
have been around for a hundred years and
are the subject of innumerable books
but popular treatments tend to emphasize
the difficult and troubling aspects of
these theories
this leaves many non-physicists with the
impression that the science einstein is
known for is very far removed from our
everyday reality
the phenomena they describe seem
abstract and esoteric things that only
matter if you've got a billion dollar
particle accelerator or are orbiting
near a supermassive black hole
except
that can't be true
physicists inhabit the same everyday
world as everybody else and we don't
just make theories up for no good reason
the modern theory of quantum mechanics
exists because physicists were led to it
by observations made right here in the
everyday reality we all deal with
this course will be all about how the
exotic physics of quantum mechanics and
even relativity connect to mundane
phenomena and technologies that we
experience in everyday life
you might be surprised to learn just how
familiar you are with these observations
we're surrounded by devices that depend
on quantum phenomena for their
operations
cameras clocks and computers among
others
but even more basic features of the
natural world are fundamentally quantum
in fact you probably see one of the key
phenomena every morning when you cook
breakfast
everything we know about quantum physics
starts with the red glow of the heating
elements in a toaster
the glow of a hot object is a very
simple and universal phenomenon take an
object any object and heat it up and it
will glow red then yellow then white
the precise color depends only on the
temperature
physicists call this black body
radiation and it doesn't matter what the
object is made of or how you get it hot
no matter what you have if you get it to
the same temperature it will glow in
exactly the same way
a clear rod of glass and a black rod of
iron heated to the same temperature emit
light of exactly the same color
physicists describe the color of objects
in terms of their spectrum the amount of
light the object emits at every possible
wavelength
what we call visible light falls in a
particular band of wavelengths from
violet light at around 400 nanometers up
to deep red light at around 700
nanometers
but of course there are many wavelengths
that our eyes don't register
as we move to wavelengths below 400
nanometers we have ultraviolet light
then x-rays and gamma rays and as we
move to wavelengths longer than 700
nanometers we have infrared then
microwave then radio waves each
wavelength has a corresponding frequency
which varies in the opposite direction
short wavelengths have high frequencies
long wavelengths have low frequencies
the two are simply related the
wavelength multiplied by the frequency
is always equal to the speed of light
so physicists tend to switch back and
forth between wavelength and frequency
using whichever is most convenient for a
particular problem
we'll do that a couple of times in this
lecture
the spectrum of light from blackbody
radiation is appealingly simple we can
represent this spectrum as a line on a
graph showing the amount of light
emitted at every possible wavelength for
an object at a given temperature
as we start at long wavelength and low
frequency and move to shorter
wavelengths and higher frequency we see
the amount of light emitted slowly
increase rising to a peak at a
particular wavelength then the amount of
light being emitted drops very rapidly
to zero
the position of the peak the particular
wavelength at which the object emits the
most light
changes with temperature
the higher the temperature the shorter
the wavelength where the peak occurs
this explains the change in color at low
temperatures the peak is off in the
infrared too long a wavelength for our
eyes to see
at room temperature the peak wavelength
is around 10 000 nanometers
as the temperature increases the peak
moves first into the red wavelengths
then yellow and so on
at a temperature of a few thousand
degrees celsius the peak spans the
entire visible spectrum so it appears
white to us
no matter what the temperature of the
object is the shape of the spectrum is
always the same on the long wavelength
side of the peak a long tail and on the
short wavelength side a steep drop
as temperature increases the total
amount of light increases and the peak
moves to shorter wavelengths but the
shape is exactly the same
a german theoretical physicist named max
planck
found a mathematical formula that
describes this shape and how it depends
on temperature in 1899
but it was purely empirical it fit the
data but there was no explanation of why
it should be that particular shape
the simple universal behavior we see in
the black body spectrum is like catnip
for theoretical physicists
because such a simple phenomenon seems
like it should have a simple and elegant
explanation
through the late 1800s a lot of really
smart people tried to explain the light
we see from hot objects but all of them
failed
the guy who finally succeeded in 1900
was the same max planck who had found
the formula for the shape the previous
year
but to do it he had to resort to a weird
trick and in the process he kicked off
what became the quantum revolution
to explain what planck's trick was and
why it was revolutionary i'll first have
to explain a model that doesn't work
because it illustrates the key ideas
more clearly
the picture i'll use comes from two
british physicists lord rayleigh and
james jeans and actually post states
planck's correct model by a few years
but it gives a clear illustration of
what the problem was and how planck's
trick fixes it
to get a simple universal curve like the
black body spectrum you want to start
with a simple and universal principle
the key idea comes from thermodynamics
and is called equipartition
as the name suggests equipartition
simply refers to an equal division of
energy you take the energy contained in
the hot object and divide it equally
among all the possible wavelengths of
light that the object could emit the
total energy of the light emitted at
each one of the allowed wavelengths is
exactly the same and when you add them
all up you should get the blackbody
spectrum
it may seem strange to talk about all
the possible wavelengths since we think
of wavelength as a continuous property
able to take on absolutely any value we
might want
continuous variables can be difficult to
work with though because they allow
infinite possibilities so physicists
often prefer to set up a mathematical
model that breaks the wavelengths up
into a limited set of possibilities that
can be numbered and counted
once we understand those and have a
formula for how they work we can use
tricks from calculus to convert the
results back to the continuous case
to understand what rayleigh and genes
were doing then we need a model of what
exactly a blackbody is that gives us a
way to count possible wavelengths
thankfully there's a nice answer for
that based on what experimentalists
actually did to observe the spectra
you take a box with a small hole in one
end and look at the light that comes out
of the hole
as long as the hole is small compared to
the size of the box this is an excellent
approximation of a black body a ray of
light that enters the hole would need to
bounce around a bunch of times with a
little light absorbed each time before
it could find its way back out
if the hole is small enough the light
will be completely absorbed long before
it could reach the exit again
that's why it's called a black body
because it absorbs light of every
possible frequency
if we see light coming out from the hole
then it has nothing to do with the light
that comes in from the outside all of
which gets absorbed
the light that comes out is just the
light that's allowed to exist inside the
box
we can figure out which wavelengths are
allowed in the box give them each an
equal share of the heat energy available
and hopefully their sum will amount to a
blackbody spectrum
it may not seem obvious that this is an
improvement but in fact finding the
wavelengths allowed in a box is a
familiar problem from the world of music
it's basically a pipe organ we can think
of an organ pipe as a box in the form of
a long tube with sound waves in it and a
small opening at one end to let some of
those waves out
differently sized pipes have different
collections of allowed wavelengths and
thus produce different tones
so what are the wavelengths that fit in
a box well they're constrained by the
walls of the box the sound wave in the
pipe or a light wave in a metal box has
to go to zero right at the wall
so only certain wave patterns can fit
the ones where the wave starts at zero
at one end and returns to zero at the
other end
this happens for particular values of
the wavelength that are simply related
to the size of the box
as we start down this road you might
worry that we're going to end up with a
spectrum that isn't really universal but
depends on the size and the shape of the
box
macroscopic objects are enormously huge
compared to the wavelength of light
though which lets physicists use a
well-known math technique to remove the
properties of the box from the final
answer
with that in mind let's look at a few
examples of wave patterns one might find
in the box our experimental black body
the simplest wave pattern that will fit
inside a box starts at zero goes up to
some maximum then comes back down to
zero at the other end
this will oscillate sometime later the
wave will start at zero go down to a
minimum then back up to zero
but the key here is that the two ends
are always fixed
this type of pattern is called a
standing wave because the nodes where
the wave is zero never change position
the simplest standing wave pattern looks
like half of a sine wave so the
wavelength associated with it is twice
the length of the box
there's also a characteristic frequency
associated with it given by the speed of
the wave divided by the wavelength
in a musical context we would call this
frequency the fundamental tone in the
case of our pipe organ it's the primary
note associated with a pipe of a given
length
but of course there are a lot of other
standing wave patterns that also satisfy
the condition of being zero at the ends
of the box
leading to the harmonics that give a
real musical instrument a richer sound
than a single sine wave at the
fundamental frequency
the next of these fits one full sine
wave into the length of the box and has
a frequency twice that of the
fundamental
this adds another fixed node right in
the center where the wave is always zero
then there's a harmonic that looks like
one and a half sine waves at three times
the fundamental frequency
then one that looks like two full sine
waves at four times the fundamental
frequency and so on
we call these wavelengths allowed modes
and we can assign each of them a number
the fundamental is one the first
harmonic is two and so on
this lets us count up the number of
allowed modes and write down the
wavelength and frequency for any
arbitrary mode
the nth mode will have a wavelength of
twice the length of the box divided by n
and a frequency of n times the
fundamental frequencies
this gives us a set of allowed modes and
now we just need to divide the energy
between them
there are in fact an infinite number of
standing wave modes that go to zero at
both ends of the box
but it's the kind of infinity that
physicists invented calculus to deal
with
this counting of modes is a well-known
type of problem and it's the most
obvious attack on the blackbody spectrum
when we try to combine these modes with
the idea of equipartition though as did
our friends rayleigh and jeans it fails
spectacularly
remember equipartition here means giving
every allowed mode an equal share of the
energy in our hot object and then adding
them up to arrive at the blackbody
spectrum
the problem is that as you go up the
scale of harmonics the modes get closer
and closer together there's a big
wavelength difference between the
fundamental and the first harmonic but
the difference between the first and
second harmonics is smaller and the
difference between the second and third
is smaller still
if we look at the total amount of light
in a narrow band of wavelengths the way
we do in an actual spectrometer the
number of allowed modes that fall within
that band just keeps going up and up as
we move the center of the band to
shorter wavelengths
this model doesn't look too bad at long
wavelengths which is why rayleigh and
jeans were working on it but it doesn't
produce a peak like we see in the real
blackbody spectrum
instead the amount of light in a given
range of wavelengths just keeps going up
and up forever
the model predicts that any hot object
should spew out an infinite amount of
light in the ultraviolet and x-ray part
of the spectrum
this is not exactly a feature you want
in a toaster
this failure is so spectacular that it
picked up a colorful name the
ultraviolet catastrophe which would be a
good name for a band
plonk started his attack on the black
body spectrum from a different place
than rayleigh and jeans but he hit an
exactly analogous problem
the obvious approach of mode counting
and equipartition just gives you way too
much light at short wavelengths and high
frequencies the result ends up looking
entirely unlike the actual spectrum we
saw earlier
and this is where planck ended up using
a desperate trick
in setting up another attempt at the
problem he introduced a new idea now
called the quantum hypothesis
about the way that light gets emitted
he said that each frequency of light
that exists in the box must be produced
by what he called an oscillator in the
walls emitting light at that particular
frequency
he didn't have a detailed physical model
for these this was more than a decade
before the modern picture of atoms was
developed
but he reasoned that something in there
must be vibrating at the frequency
associated with the light
he assigned each of these oscillators a
characteristic energy equal to its
frequency multiplied by some small
number
then he added the really critical rule
that a given oscillator can emit energy
only in integer multiples of this
characteristic energy
one unit two units three units
but never one and a half units or pi
units
he was doing this to set up a particular
calculus trick and expect it to take the
small number to zero at the end of the
problem which would go back to a smooth
and continuous distribution of energy
to his surprise though this method
worked out
only if that small number was not zero
in which case the quantum hypothesis
fixed the ultraviolet catastrophe
to see how it works we can go back to
our picture of a simple set of modes
each getting an equal share of the
energy available from heat but add in
planck's quantum hypothesis
let's say that the energy share is low
enough that it's just six times the
characteristic energy of the fundamental
mode in that case the black body would
emit six units of light at the
fundamental frequency
the first harmonic mode number two has
twice the frequency of the fundamental
so its characteristic energy is twice as
big
thus we get three units of light at this
frequency
mode three has a frequency three times
the fundamental so it emits two units of
light
when we get to mode four though planck's
rule kicks in
this has a frequency four times that of
the fundamental mode so it should get to
emit one-fourth as many units of light
but that would be one and a half units
and only integer values are allowed
so thanks to the quantum hypothesis we
only get one unit of light at this
frequency which is less than we would
have expected
as the frequency keeps going up the
characteristic energy gets larger and
larger and eventually is bigger than the
share of the energy that would be
allotted to that frequency
in our model that happens at mode 7
which should emit 6 7 of a unit of light
it's only allowed to emit light in
integer units though so in fact it can't
emit any light and neither can any of
the higher frequency modes
planck's quantum rule
thus does exactly the thing we need to
fix the ultraviolet catastrophe it
squashes the emission of light in short
wavelength high frequency modes
at some particular frequency the
characteristic energy needed to emit one
unit of light becomes greater than the
amount of energy available from heat for
emitting light at that frequency and the
emission gets shut off
if you're paying close attention you
might be saying wait doesn't stopping
the emission at high frequency free up
the energy that would have been
allocated to those modes
that's a good catch the full treatment
of this has to adjust the share of the
energy allotted to each mode based on
the quantum hypothesis cutting things
off
again this is exactly the kind of
problem that we invented calculus to
solve
this picture combining the idea of
equipartition with the quantum
hypothesis
gives us a very nice explanation of the
shape of the blackbody spectrum that we
see
starting at long wavelengths and moving
down the characteristic energies are
very low so we just see an increase in
the total amount of light in a
particular band of wavelengths due to
the increasing number of modes in that
wavelength range
at short wavelength though the
characteristic energy gets too big so
while the number of modes keeps going up
for many of them we get no light emitted
at all
this cutoff happens very rapidly which
is why the short wavelength side of the
peak drops off faster than the long
wavelength tail
the amount of energy available due to
heat increases as the temperature
increases which means that the frequency
where the quantum cutoff happens goes up
with temperature
that's why the peak moves to shorter
wavelengths for hotter objects
when you carry through all the gory
mathematical details what you end up
with is exactly the formula that planck
had found empirically in 1899
but now with a grounding in the
fundamental physics of equipartition
it also gives you a very particular
value for the small number that
multiplies the frequency to get the
characteristic energy what we now call
planck's constant
in modern units it's
6.626 times 10 to the minus 34 joules
per hertz
or 33 zeros to the right of the decimal
point before you get to the 6626
that's an extremely small number to be
sure but it's very definitely not zero
planck resorted to the quantum
hypothesis out of desperation but it was
a smashing success his blackbody formula
has been tested over and over at
temperatures from the hottest stars to
the cold of interstellar space
the cosmic microwave background
radiation light left over from just a
few hundred thousand years after the big
bang fits perfectly to a black body
spectrum with a temperature of only 2.71
degrees above absolute zero
astronomers use planck's formula to
determine the temperature of distant
objects by the light we observe from
them
the touchless infrared thermometers that
have become so common in regular health
screenings do the same to figure out
body temperature
the idea even shows up in the arts when
photographers and lighting designers
talk about color temperature
that's based on the black body formula
planck's black body model is a brilliant
success and made him a famous and
influential figure in german physics the
german network of national laboratories
are the max planck institutes in his
honor
planck himself was never entirely happy
with his trick though despite its
success
he held out hope that some other
physicist would find a clever and
elegant trick that would explain the
blackbody formula without resorting to
this ugly business of oscillators that
can only emit integer multiples of some
characteristic energy
this was not to be though because in
1905 an unknown patent clerk in
switzerland with dreams of greater
things
picked up this idea and applied it to
the light itself and quantum mechanics
really got rolling
that's a topic for our next lecture
though for now the important thing to
remember is that any time you see a
heating element glow that cheery red as
you toast the slice of bread you're
looking at the place where quantum
physics got its start